l'ennemi public numéro un du monde
occidental le trac été retrouvé et tué
[Musique]
il ya quelques jours j'ai rencontré john
brennan d'abord conseiller spécial de
barack obama lorsqu'il était à la maison
blanche pour son premier mandat puis
directeur de la cia donc l' agence de
renseignement la plus connue au monde
qui opèrent à l'extérieur du sol
américain une influence de john brennan
et on peut le dire très important avec
barack obama il a joué un rôle immense
dans une opération tout simplement
historique
l'élimination de celui qui était à
l'époque l'ennemi public numéro un aux
etats-unis oussama ben laden aujourd'hui
il nous dévoile donc les coulisses de
cette opération historique mais aussi
controversé
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler dans
quelques instants et cette vidéo est
donc la première vidéo sur cette
nouvelle chaîne youtube dans les
prochains jours vous allez trouver sur
cette chaîne
des reportages des enquêtes des formats
inédits que je vais travailler avec le
reste de l'équipe d'ugo décrypte du coup
c'est une tout début de cette nouvelle
aventure si jamais ça vous plaît
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour nous
soutenir et ne pas rater les vidéos
suivantes
oussama ben laden est né en arabie
saoudite d'une famille de très riche
industriel du pays est très proche
d'ailleurs de la famille royale
il est décrit par sa mère comme étant un
enfant qui à l'école est timide mais
tout simplement brillant lors de ses
études il va se rapprocher de groupes
islamistes radicaux et en 1979 il part
en afghanistan pour lutter avec des
combattants djihadistes contre
l'occupation par les soviétiques et ses
quelques années après dix ans après en
fait qu'il va co fondé l'organisation
terroriste islamiste que tout le monde
connaît aujourd'hui
al qaïda et en 1998 ben laden appelle à
tuer les américains et leurs alliés
civil ou militaire où qu'ils soient et
trois ans plus tard l'on septembre 2001
al-qaïda revendique les attaques contre
le world trade center à new york et le
pentagone faisant près de 3000 victimes
je
[Applaudissements]
pendant les années qui suivent
et malgré les efforts de la cia la
traque de ben laden est au point mort il
n'y a aucune avancée majeure et barack
obama tout juste arrivée à la maison
blanche s'impatiente
en 2009 juste après son élection donc
barack obama a réuni ses plus proches
conseillers en matière de sécurité
et parmi ses conseillers à l'époque il
ya donc john brennan un proche d'obama
en septembre 2010 le directeur de la cia
à l'époque léon panetta annonce au
président des états unis qu'un messager
potentiel de ben laden semble avoir été
localisés ils habiteraient dans une base
à abbottabad au pakistan et quelques
mois plus tard cette piste se confirme
la cia identifie un individu ressemblant
à ben laden et qui habite dans cette
base à partir de là à la maison blanche
les réunions s'enchaînent et une
opération très minutieuse et très
nombreuses se prépare et walter borst
6,9 dans la salle de crise où se
tiennent les réunions les caméras sont
recouvertes les micros sont recouverts
au cas où dans le doute
aucunes retransmission des permise par
vidéoconférence le secret de rester le
plus total et donc toutes les
précautions sont prises
tracfin les détails de l'opération sont
ensuite discutées et l'option d'un
bombardement sur la base est assez vite
écartée pour deux raisons assez
importante
d'abord première raison cela pourrait
entraîner des dommages collatéraux
importants avec des victimes civiles et
les etats-unis sont déjà suffisamment
critiqué là dessus pour ajouter un autre
élément allant dans ce sens et au delà
de ça un bombardement ne permettrait pas
d'être sûr que la personne tuée au sein
de la base et bien ben laden et pas une
autre personne qui pourrait lui
ressembler obama le side attaque best
l'assaut par hélicoptère est donc retenu
mais cette méthode compliquer le
calendrier et les inquiétudes persistent
autour de l'environnement d'abbottabad
quelques semaines avant l'opération
l'amiral mcraven commandant des forces
spéciales
armée dévoile le plan du raid malgré les
inquiétudes et le risque forcément
important il pense son équipe capable de
mener l'assaut avec succès
vendredi 29 avril après de multiples
tâtonnements et bien barack obama valide
l'idée de cet assaut il se tiendra donc
le dimanche 1er mai 2011 soit il ya donc
tout juste dix ans à 14 heures les
hélicoptères et les forces spéciales
américaines d'école d'afghanistan
direction abbottabad au pakistan et vers
15h30 heure de washington
00h30 heure pakistanaise les
hélicoptères arrive près de la base
[Musique]
pendant ce temps-là obama et ses
conseillers dont john brennan donc
suivre avec attention
minute par minute le déroulé de
l'opération
le reste est un crack photo baladeur la
tension est à son comble et le commando
de trois canadair oussama ben laden est
mort
et pourtant à ce moment là aucun
applaudissement ne retentit au sein de
la maison blanche et pour john brennan
est bien le plus dur de la mission
commence à peine
barack obama décide alors de s'adresser
au monde de prendre la parole d'annoncer
au monde entier que l'homme le plus
recherché de la planète
oussama ben laden est maintenant décédé
dans le bureau ovale de la maison
blanche il peaufine son discours
s'assure d'avoir le bon ton notamment
auprès de ses conseillers dont john
brennan à ce moment là l'émotion
l annonce de la mort de ben laden
aux etats unis des milliers d'américains
descendent dans la rue pour exprimer
donc leur joie ça se passe à washington
espace aussi à new york autour de ground
zero le site où se dressaient à l'époque
les tours jumelles
[Musique]
et
près de dix ans après l'assaut la
méthode utilisée par les états unis à
agir comme ça seul sans la validation de
personnes d'autres faits encore très
polémique
c'est donc une opération qui reste
controversé en 2020 le premier ministre
pakistanais imran khan a déclaré que ben
laden était mort en martyr que ce raid
avait détérioré les relations entre le
pakistan et les états unis et qu'il
avait aussi humilié les pakistanais
autre chose et c'est l'une des critiques
les plus importantes que l'on peut
apporter j'en parlais d'ailleurs déjà en
début de vidéo certaines méthodes
employées par la cia pour obtenir des
informations sont extrêmement
controversée est souvent qualifiée
d'inhumaine un rapport du sénat
américain dévoilés en 2014 accuse
notamment la cia de techniques de
torture avancée des techniques qui en
plus d'être jugée humiliante et d'être
dénoncée par de très nombreuses ong
n'ont pas nécessairement permis
d'avancer dans la recherche de ben laden
bref tout n'est pas rose dans cette
opération ni plus largement dans les
pratiques de la cia au contraire
d'ailleurs et ça me semblait nécessaire
de le rappeler aujourd'hui par ailleurs
en tuant le fondateur d'al qaïda les
états unis ont éliminé un symbole
important du terrorisme et du jihadisme
à l'international mais quel est l'impact
réel sur le développement d'al qaïda est
bien pour certain oussama ben laden
avait encore un rôle important au sein
de l'organisation
alors que pour d'autres il était pas mal
en retrait depuis ces dernières années
en tout cas entre 2011 et aujourd'hui al
qaïda beaucoup à évoluer notamment avec
en parallèle l'émergence d'un autre
groupe l'état islamique
mais al qaïda reste présent dans
plusieurs pays du monde notamment au
sahel au yémen en
ac ou encore en syrie vous le disais
pour ne pas rater les vidéos suivantes
pensez à vous abonner à cette nouvelle
chaîne youtube puisque à partir de
maintenant il y a deux chaînes hugo
décrite il y à une chaîne you go
décrypte vous allez retrouver les accuse
jour c'est la chaîne qui existe depuis
des années et donc pour voir les actus
du jour et découvrir ce contenu je vous
mets le lien directement en descriptions
et puis il ya cette seconde chaîne cette
nouvelle chaîne sur laquelle vous allez
retrouver dans les prochains jours donc
nos reportages sur lequel on travaille
en ce moment des contenus exclusifs
comme celui ci et d'autres nouveautés
que je le sais vous vous plaire qui
viennent dans les prochains jours du
coup pour c'est à vous abonner pour nous
soutenir
et puis vous aussi pour ne pas rater les
vidéos suivantes ça prend quelques
secondes c'est gratuit et ça nous aide
beaucoup
cette vidéo est réalisée à l'occasion de
la sortie des mémoires de john brennan
publié chez talent édition du gauche
mais ça vous intéresse mais la question
de la cia était question de sécurité et
de terrorisme vous intéresse bien vous
conseille cet ouvrage vous mes liens
directement en descriptions écoutez je
crois je vous dis prenez soin de vous
pressent de vos proches et on se dit à
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo